who connected to you as the
Jay out there out I don't have my
glasses on you said you don't want to
see her oh you have a j that's out there
that's the person that sat down okay
so wait go ahead keep going but the
Jay's living yeah well and also passed
oh I'm Jay I'm Jackie no but I know you
introduced me as Jack no the one who
passed is Jay yes yeah but through that
room yes okay so the Jay that's passed
through that room wants to be
acknowledged the month of October or the
10th of a month is going to have some
type of meaning birthday or anniversary
so there's some reference to that um and
then I want to talk about a middle name
with an M or there's a name that's got
like an MR so think like Mari moris Mor
maray Marie Morris Morris Maurice who is
that Morris Joe Morris was his name okay
so the middle name is Morris yeah okay
so what I see that as being a uh like a
dad is there a connection to a father
figure for that yes yeah okay so I feel
like if the J connection
is the the person then that Jay's also
ped yes okay oh I I just got I just
caught up with what you just said so he
is Joe Morris yeah yes so it's not two
separate people it's the same person
right ding ding ding so you're watching
the light bulb go off in my head as I'm
doing this um I don't know if there are
twins in that family but they're showing
me the sign of Gemini so the sign of
Gemini is the sign of the twin and that
would be like late May June she's Gemini
Gemini okay so this would be dad's way
then of acknowledging his presence I
don't know he had sepsis or if somebody
had some if somebody had some type of
like multi-organ system shutdown but
there's a feeling of a multi-organ
system shutdown that I'm supposed to
highlight and they're showing me pink
roses when I say pink roses that's their
way of expressing love but I feel like
there's something that was done with
them or given or there's some type of
symbol of that like you know I have them
we painted them there's something about
that one of the things that I'm also
feeling is that I want to go out of the
state that I'm in so I want to go to the
east coast so I don't know if there's
anybody on the East Coast or there's a
connection to the east coast but there's
a reference to the east coast
specifically showing me Harvard and
Massachusetts so I don't know if there's
a conversation about Boston or there's a
conversation about that but I need to
bring that up and then I feel like I'm
supposed to also highlight that there's
a um is Mom still living is there a mom
still living yes I want to say hi to the
mom so hi to mom so Joe's saying hi to
Mom happy birthday this week so happy
birthday now somebody's got a birthday
now in the family where there's
something celebratory that I'm supposed
to talk about brother yeah his up okay
and then I think there's four kids in
that family or somebody's one of four
three kids four three there's four kids
so mom might have
miscarried she does I don't know yeah
there's there's a there's a reference to
that um I don't know if Dad's recently
pass but my feeling is that somebody's
gone not too long ago yes yes that's
true I don't know if he can you he hear
me yeah what she saying okay yes he just
he passed away a month ago oh that's
definitely recent okay so he's
definitely seeing this as a way of
coming in was there an issue about the
shoes that you were wearing today or am
I supposed to bring up your shoes oh
that's funny I almost didn't wear these
shoes because I didn't think they'd be
safe to walk in because I just had eye
surgery okay cuz I feel
like I feel like I'm supposed to say
that I was with you when you were having
the conversation about whether or not
you should wear the shoes and then
there's talk about knocking down a wall
or taking a wall
down um yeah it it it could
um so I don't mean like met I don't mean
like metaphorical walls like somebody's
boundaries like knocking down the
emotional wall I mean like a wall like
an actual wall an actual wall in my
mom's house needs to be taken down and
my mom needs to move out while it's
being done okay so this is this would be
his way of saying he sees what's taking
place he's telling me he's met up with
this is kind of weird because you're
sitting in front of me Howard who's
Howard um well he has met hoe so you
knew him yeah okay well he's being being
formal he's referring to you as Howard
like I met Howard um so he's
acknowledging Howard he would do that
and then you have a
gold uh I don't know a gold there's
nothing in here I could point to there's
like a you know when someone has a like
a certificate and it's got a gold seal
on it or a gold stamp uhhuh he's tell me
to bring up the gold seal or the gold
stamp like almost like if somebody got
somebody graduated and they get like the
gold seal on the diploma or they
something about that their kids yeah my
both my kids just graduated with their
masters okay and one was from Cardinal
and gold which was his school and um
because he's putting gold on this and
then did he write a textbook or did he
write um he was no he was writing the
story of his life but never got to
finish it so two things one he's making
me feel like the thing that he was
writing is not like a novel it feels
like it's a it's a I'm going to call it
a textbook because I feel like there's
teaching in it so whatever his intention
was about writing his story was to teach
people about the experience and the
journey that he went through and the
lessons that he learned from it correct
yes yes okay and then you know
that um and again we are not live right
no okay was there money embezzled from
him
um not directly but it kind of is now um
from people that are working with him
I'm going to tell you that the feeling
he's giving me is that monies that would
have been part of his family plot his
family pot his his bank vault whatever
that is was mismanaged or utilized in an
improper way yeah and he did not do
anything to protect it he's taking the
responsibility for
it yeah that makes sense he's also
telling me that you're not crazy you
actually did smell him like you smelled
him and that's called Clare aliance is
when you get that smell
um and I think it happened in the car so
I think you were like by yourself and
you got like a whiff of something and
I'm supposed to say like I was with you
when you did this I don't recall that
yeah he's making me feel like I'm like I
I am getting like a smell of a of a of a
like a person's scent and the reason why
I'm saying that is I used to tease my
mom that she smelled like baby vitamin
sometimes right so I don't know whatever
it is that she took and I'd be like you
smell like baby vitamins so weird that
you would bring that up now because I am
absolutely sure that Jackie farted
minute ago I was just going to say that
I just going to make that chill you are
amazing I think you're smelling my
f um Noe I don't think it's that um I I
I think it's I think it's uh it's her
dad and I think he wants me to
acknowledge the scent or the smell so if
you did not have this in your own
personal space then tell your mom he was
there when she smelled the shirt the
pillow the something that would have no
it's definitely a it's an inhale of of
of smelling something is Stephen your
brother yeah yes yeah that's my that's
the validation so what they do I I I I I
discussed this with Howe I have a little
OCD and I read very much where I need a
lot of validation so when I make a
statement and it doesn't kind of
recognize immediately at first they'll
back it up with something because they
know I'm not going to drop it so they go
let me back it up with something factual
so I always say like I'm a psychic dog
and when I get it right they give me a
treat my treat's validation um right on
you are so right on this is amazing I
need you to know that your your dad's
okay and I know that this might be like
recent for you but you kind of knew that
he wasn't going to be here yeah and I
feel like for anybody that's listening
we can prepare for someone's passing my
mom had terminal lung cancer I prepared
for it but when it actually happens now
you have to experience it you know and
now you're going through the experience
of of navigating a life that he's
claiming was well- lived a life that was
you know beautiful and he's making me
feel like he wants to be celebrated not
not live live in the light of love like
that's the excuse me that's the way that
he wants me to
feel